first of all I wanted to feel reasonably
confident that I knew what I was talking
about in private I've liked learning and
talking about physics ever since I was a
student in fact talking about the
subject as soon as one has a general
idea of the notions and the language is
a great way to learn things since more
experienced people can then correct your
misconceptions and you really learn
through that process but referring to
physics in my research or organizing
public activity surrounding physics is
claiming a good deal more competence
than might be required for conversations
so that took longer the fact that the
number theory community tends to be a
pretty tough minded crowd was probably
part of the reason for my silence
they're not easily impressed by ideas
unless you show that you can do
something definite with them so I needed
to have theorems results and pretty
concrete directions before admitting
that physics was an important part of my
thinking I sometimes like to compare
theorems and definite results to money
in the bank then when you're just
describing ideas and general philosophy
you're using that money maybe even going
into debt
so then you need to get back to proving
theorems I should stress that I think
this kind of skepticism on the part of
the community is a good thing overall
meeting the challenge of skeptics is
definitely an important part of
organizing one's thoughts thereby making
them more precise and useful even if
it's difficult sometimes perhaps a more
weighty aspect of the decision to admit
the influence of physics openly now
there's a certain sense of scientific
obligation to put it in slightly
grandiose terms it's clear we're at the
place in scientific history where the
interplay of ideas between physics and
number theory is quite important and
young young people especially energetic
young people should be paying attention
to it there are many indications such as
the work on motives and Feynman diagrams
all the new work on conformal field
theory and module
forms arithmetic aspects of trans
Simon's theory astrology and the
Langlands program and many many others I
feel strongly that the interface has
important insights to offer to people
working in arithmetic geometry but also
to people working in fundamental physics
especially quantum field theory and
strings even if I personally say some
foolish things while advertising the
connections I feel like I shouldn't be
hiding from a serious discourse in
private as well as in public